one star who's lived through her own
real-life scandals is Mischa Barton the
former star of the OSI made headlines
when a video surfaced of her melting
down in her backyard now Mischa is
speaking out about it publicly for the
first time with dr. Phil I think it was
completely loose nation I have no idea
what I was talking about it was this
January when Mischa was seen in her
backyard rambling incoherently and
screaming were you seeing something or
was it an auditory hallucination a
visual it was both before i black out
and don't remember anything it was both
auditory and visual Mischa was then
voluntarily hospitalized for a mental
evaluation she later said she had been
given a date-rape drug
at a party and then the whole part like
outside is just blackouts it was quite a
tumble from Barton's exciting days
starting in 2003 as Hollywood's newest
it girl starring on the OC The OC was
like an overnight success and I was the
youngest of everyone on the cast at that
time after leaving the OC Misha began
her downward spiral first with the DUI
in 2007 two years later she started on
the short-lived series the beautiful
life everybody was very concerned that I
wasn't ready and there was a lot of
pressure to do right by the show and a
whole new series that pressure Mischa
tells dr. Phil involved people
medicating her to keep her working speed
no not as a certainly just that also
things like xanax and things really take
away like the anxiety of work and like
the public eye and I was getting pretty
stressed out so in general they were
just prescribing things they probably
had no right to be prescribing that
episode of dr. Phil airs on Monday and
we will be watching
you